hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here to ask you how well do you
know markiplier so we've got a quiz here
that says how well do you know
markiplier hard version so let's put it
to the test I've got a bunch more
quizzes so I can figure out who the [ __ ]
I am anyway
sup answer the question buddy what is
marks full name mark pryor mark Edward
Fishbach or mark Edwards
Finch Bach which is an amazing name and
I would love to be called that but
frankly I have to answer honestly to my
own ideals which is this one which
university did he go to University of
Cincinnati who is Mark sibling Thomas
Jason
Fishbach well that's not correct
none of these are correct it's not
Michael Jason Fishbach it's not Thomas
Jason Fishbach it's not Sabrina Edward
Fishbach found Lily Edward Fishbach
because my brother's name isn't Thomas
Jason Fishbach it's Jason Thomas
Fishbach yes you heard it here first I
have revealed through the world that my
brother's real first name is not Thomas
as he would have you believe no nay he
goes by his middle name so I guess he's
manatees are cracking here how old is he
well
pretty damn old but not that old and not
that young and definitely not that young
what was they doing when I was 20 I have
no goddamn idea I was still in college I
still had hopes to be an engineer nada
not a dumb youtuber on YouTube but I'm
27 and proud of it you need to worry as
the provisional I've never said those
words in my life when was he born well
judging by the previous question you'd
be able to extrapolate an answer of
maybe maybe just maybe I was born in 89
where is he living right now how the
heck am I supposed to know I'm not a
stalker I'm gonna answer that one that's
all folks what is it what is this
I answered six of eight ways six of
eight
wait at one hang on a second well hey
wait hang on
what did I answer wrong cuz I know I
answered one of them wrong what you say
I'm not mad let's try this again on a
different quiz and hopefully there's
gonna be some correct answers here and
not some bullshitter e in the background
my name is that I was born on this date
I was born on Oahu Hawaii
God why does everyone say oh why who I
say Honolulu cuz that's where it [ __ ]
was 9 Air Force Base it was an army it's
a milk but whatever it was what does
everyone say Oahu Hawaii it's [ __ ]
Honolulu I was born in Honolulu that's
where what hum Lulu is on Oahu but you
know what they don't say they [ __ ] in
on Oahu Hawaii doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense
it's Honolulu oh oh what's that oh
[ __ ] uh wahoo [ __ ] Honolulu here
let's zoom in on this military hospital
picture ah there we go
Tripler Army here I was born here it's
[ __ ] pink that's it's [ __ ] pink
that well that's where I was born pink
mustache and all right out of my momma
just hello everybody I just that's how
that's that's I was born I just burst
out everybody there fully clothed and
muscular
hello everybody my name is markiplier
I'm gonna be a youtuber when I'm 27 but
before that I'm gonna fail a whole lot
at everything hahahaha
alright anyway continuing this [ __ ]
quiz so in in Honolulu and in hospital I
wasn't for like when people say that I'm
born on Oahu on an Air Force Base which
I don't think there's an Air Force Base
on Oahu but I'm not sure about that
that makes it sound like I was born in
the middle of the runway my mom sprinted
out into the field
oh I'm having a baby that's how my mom
says I'm sorry mom
my mom is probably watching this I'm
sorry that's not how you sound I know
that she sprinted out onto the tarmac
drop trou and had a baby huh I'm sorry
mom I'm already committed I've already
apologized so I'm gonna keep going with
the joke so that's what that that's what
that sounds like
anyway so here not to get sidetracked
let's see which movie has Marc starred
in starred in starred in you know the
rocks one movie that one movie that the
rock did the the rock movie you know the
rock movie the rock with George Harrison
Wilson's rip wilt Wilford Brimley and uh
the other guy from the Saw movies yeah
you know I was in the rock movie that
was it yeah those me that's me I was
that guy i I didn't star I haven't been
in any YouTube red movies I was had a
little little thing in the Smosh movie
was marks first video no that's a lie
it's a this is a lie it's a it's a damn
dirty I know if you go to my chin I I'm
fully aware of the fact that if you go
to my channel and you sort by a oldest
you get a very different view luck we're
not gonna watch my let's just do a video
where I watch my videos I know I know if
you do oldest it'll be like oh yeah did
this video this one at this one no
that's not the first what this is the
first one my first let's play I've ever
done this is markiplier here with my
brand-new let's play of amnesia the Dark
Descent notice all the spit that's in my
mouth is because I didn't know how to
talk properly and I didn't know how to
enunciate and I never talked before
we're gonna do a side-by-side comparison
to see how four and a half years of time
have passed by to evolve the voice that
is me alright hello everybody markiplier
here with my brand new let's play of
amnesia the Dark Descent just gonna
create a profile here I heard this game
is quite scary alright hello everybody
this is markiplier here with my brand
new let's play of M
the Dark Descent just creating a profile
here I've heard this game is quite scary
boom got it nailed it
do it side by side flyby do lots of
passes on this one see it's me it's just
it's [ __ ] me I don't know what I've
heard at one point I'm done brew beer
look it sounds like me but from five
years ago
it's [ __ ] me it's still it's still
look listen to that huh it's weird right
the voices ah whatever [ __ ] it I don't
know I just my point is again I get
sidetracked in these quizzes my point is
that means it's not the first one the
first one was the first part of amnesia
the dark said because I had to play the
game before I could do the koppel get it
to everybody it's on my old channel I
can show you it you go to youtube.com
slash user slash markiplier oh it's me
it's old me even older than old me it's
original old me it's like ancient old me
and look that it's the compilation and
then this one this sad video here hello
everybody markiplier here and I have a
very very important announcement to tell
it's me this is absolutely the most
important message that I'll probably
ever get to you guys for absolutely the
most important message Hall you didn't
think you'd ever have a more important
message than to tell you that guys that
my channel died do you ever wonder why
my youtube channel is markiplier game
and not markiplier it's because this
[ __ ] one is big thank you to [ __ ]
deleted my adsense on this one [ __ ] you
YouTube's good at bargain look it's my
old icon the old original icon oh you
stabbed [ __ ] again I got sidetracked
apologize not the point of this
what is marks most popular video good
question I have no idea probably five
nights at freddys ah it is next by five
minutes Freddie yawn Derek a lhasa for
now meow Oh meow still pull him through
Oh me I was close to my art eventually
I'll make another video like me I do
plan on doing that very soon it's gonna
be uh it's gonna be special I already
have the idea for it so I'll do that
soon I'll do that soon actually this is
about dedicating like
so many hours just cutting out my mouth
it's very boring Oh baby plier haaaaax
Tim ah so cool
man was with these games and getting a
bajillion views that's a weird man okay
but why is that then why does that have
eight million views holy [ __ ] man it's
like flipping through memory lane like
my god
all popcorns up there I love popcorn
that's both a statement and a happy
about that thing oh that's cool
I really haven't looked at this ah man I
haven't looked at this in a long time Oh
markiplier walks down the street yes
let's watch it again I don't care [ __ ]
you yeah but to make a video where I
watch my own video cuz I can cuz that's
me how well do you know markiplier if
you're in not surprised that I'm doing
this [ __ ] God how long ago was that
oh god it was last year ah [ __ ] it
wasn't that oh oh man oh jeez aw it's
memories what was the point of this what
what am I doing here it's funny because
people go to these videos over time and
like people find them over time and it's
such a mixture of like very old videos
that are popular and then very new
videos that are popular I always like
looking back at what I've done but
usually I only look back at like the old
videos and then more recent videos it's
just kind of like I don't know it's kind
of jarring to be to be looking at the
stuff and remember each one individually
like god this is probably the most click
baited thing I've ever done markiplier
gets banned from YouTube and it's just
like I was as we were just talking about
this story about Elysian Park good god
we did a video in Elysian Park it's a
very lovely place ah the first video I
did with Jack Oh drunk prop on the only
thing we ever did of that oh man god
that was such good times
cuz it's weird because going through
this and jumping through all of time
it's just it's really like it's
heartwarming for me because it's like
seeing all that I've accomplished and
that's what I like about the videos that
I've been doing recently especially with
going out with fans and whatnot because
I can look back and they're memorable
it's not just a
a throwaway video that I put up because
I needed to put up a video it's a video
you know videos that I can remember and
look back and I know exactly what was
happening there and I know why it was
happening and I know what was going on
in my life I'm getting lost in nostalgia
now this is not the point of this it's
just it's just cool to see anyway I'm
I'm done being nostalgia stand being
[ __ ] let's finish this quiz out it's
for Nath part one is is the answer to
that what year did Mark start making
videos we just went over this it's 2012
what YouTube group is mark a part of
rebel mode is an easy one what color did
mark first dye his hair and it was pink
last question but it's easy how tall is
Mark claim why I claim I claim I'm a
great many different heights I I think 4
foot 2 is the most common one though BAM
I'm a genius I know me do you know me
cuz I know me and that was a fun fun
adventure I like taking these quizzes
it's say it seems weird on the surface
to take these quizzes and look at them
and be like oh man what is this silly
crap but the reason I do it is because
it makes me remember like it makes me
remember not only what I've done in the
past but what I do is like ingrained in
you guys's minds and so that's important
for me to put out good things so that
you remember good things about me I mean
I guess you could remember bad things
about me it's totally fine to like but
my history is all laid out in these
quizzes and it brings up memories and it
brings back good times and bad times it
can bring up sad times too but that's
important because it's part of your past
and it's part of my past in this
scenario so I hope you enjoyed this one
this was a fun adventure I really didn't
know where this one was gonna go and it
went some pretty surprising places so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome to the
video where I ask you guys again realize
how much you know about me cuz
apparently it's not a lot how old am I
taesik wrong daddy that's a last time
where was I born California wrong No Shh
would you believe me if I told you this
mic doesn't work yes and I've been
wasting everybody's time no where was it
work what what did you say you walk yes
you get the whipping prize you said who
I've been looking for someone to say
that forever not really something I
should take a hard stance on anyway you
fail okay all right bend over
Oh
look at me in return you don't want me
to do it do it as hard as I did it to
you who's your favorite youtuber you
know who my favorite youtuber is me it's
true I'm always taller a place of origin
California ethnicity white Hispanic
paper color red where'd you go to school
high school or college
pick your paper uh Warren high school
alright so you didn't like college no I
dropped out ptoo yeah anyway yeah what's
my favorite color green one you get a
reward lash oh god dad
alright what's your name I'm Ellie's
okay what's my name
mark full name mark Claire is there a
full
we got a jokester we ourselves a
jokester
who's this favorite youtuber it was my
favorite YouTube that guy right there
nope congratulations any closing
thoughts my brother and I love you oh I
did it did it did it what is the first
video I ever uploaded it was a Minecraft
video
know how much do you know about not very
much and fortunately let's go is gum fun
then I'm from I was born in Hawaii
oh really yes I wanna tell you I'm not
all right
okay that's good you failed the quiz you
have one redeeming question
okay
okay congratulations
because remember you lost okay come on
no she's trying to doggie feel wrong
all right what's your name Jasmine okay
what are you doing here when was I born
that is correct
technically speaking ah how many YouTube
channels has he had yeah how many
YouTube channels has I have to the
answer is actually four markiplier
markiplier - markiplier live streams and
then marklar games you know the more you
know alright you fail the quiz our
goodbyes my brother
awesome
it's okay
cover
you